o sujeito contemporâneo é a primeira
coisa que ele faz quando acorda ele vai
se espreguiçar vamos o psicanalista e
ele vai pegar no seu órgão sexual
o smartphone
o smartphone hoje é o que nos conecta
com o mundo é através de é através dele
que a gente realiza as nossas fantasias
é através dele que de uma certa maneira
vamos viver o inferno e o céu na vida
cotidiana
ou seja o smartphone ele se tornou um
órgão não é um órgão do nosso corpo
acoplado o nosso corpo mas percebamos
que há 50 mil anos mais ou menos
quando pensamos em lucy por exemplo não
é nós perceberemos que lucy é tinha já a
mesma base genética que nós ou seja nós
somos o mesmo animal há 50 mil anos
só que nós vemos com uma mutação uma
estranha mutação que fez com que há 50
mil anos fosse possível transmitir para
a geração seguinte
aquilo que a pessoa aprendeu ea pessoa
depois o neto poderia transmitir o que o
seu pai aprendeu do pai e do avô
o que fazer então e que nesses 50 mil
anos é ouvir uma base de conhecimento
adquirido de linguagem absolutamente
enorme que nos distancia completamente
do animal ou seja a linguagem nos
desnaturalizar ou nós não podemos dizer
mais que nós somos seres da natureza
simplesmente não é isso minha
cachorrinha mia por exemplo é super
espertinha ela está conosco há 12 12
anos
minha ela ela não gosta de game of
thrones ela sai da sala ela se eu tirar
a mala vai fazer xixi do lado do piano
em sinal de protesto
ou seja é muito muito espertinho qual é
o problema
minha não vai saber passar toda o país
voltando aqui as coisas não deixa eu
voltar aqui ela não vai conseguir passar
toda a experiência para exatamente a aaa
cria dela vai precisar passar pelo mano
então steven chegou de mostra que por um
lado é um filósofo da ciência que gosto
muito
se por um lado nós somos seres
biologicamente darwinianos mas a nossa
mente ela é
lamarck ana não é isso é um ponto
importante a gente consegue transmitir e
de tal maneira que por exemplo que um
jovem adolescente hoje com 16 anos ele
aprende em um dia
esse mesmo jovem na época feudal
demoraria a vida dele inteira pra
aprender
percebemos isso voltamos então século 21
como império das imagens o que isso
significa significa que não vivemos mais
100 câmeras sem imagens somos
bombardeados permanentemente por imagens
não é
antes se usava câmeras por exemplo para
vigiar determinado sujeito hoje somos
todos absolutamente vigiados
se vocês forem fazer uma compra em
londres
andando pelas ruas passarão por mais de
300 câmeras
eu peguei no meu prédio e queria um
prédio só com 14 apartamentos colocar
uma câmera do elevador e eu falei pra
que o elevador um lugar sagrado a gente
mete o dedo no nariz ajeitar a calcinha
da uma massa em alguém no final do dia e
fica o porteiro vendo a gente ali
isso porque teve um tal de um crime da
mala como se a gente fosse ali se todo
dia pra esquartejando alguém levanta
pela mala ou seja o que a gente percebe
é que no mundo contemporâneo bombardeado
por câmeras nós tivemos esse declínio da
intimidade daquilo que começa nos anos
80 por exemplo quando a gente tem até
deus né ele vai pelos smartphones né a
gente percebe isso
mas onde há exatamente essa questão é do
self onde não vale mais a pena você ir
é ver a mona lisa você tem que tirar um
self com a mona lisa do lado né a gente
sabe disso
ou seja gente goza muito mais da imagem
tive uma paciente que ela perdeu o
smartphone dela uma viagem à europa ela
voltou da viagem como se ela não tivesse
feito uma viagem foi uma frustração
enorme porque ela não pôde exatamente
colocar ali o que ela queria que ela
postar que está a apostar não é isso
ora o que percebemos então é que esses
elfes o instagram ele coloca digamos
assim a melhor imagem nossa ele vai
querer colocar aquela imagem bonita com
filtro naturalmente mas nós na verdade
nós não somos essa imagem
o mais importante é vocês entenderem que
nós somos a 60 imagens que não possamos
instagram completa no dente com a
calcinha aparecendo campo é a prova
disso é que a gente não joga fora essa
imagem vai acumulando uma enormidade de
lixo
dessas 60 as fotos que são 60 fotos que
são as verdadeiras fotos de quem nós
somos
ou seja se essa insegurança na sísmica
que nos pega faz faz com que a gente se
desce dependa de mais exatamente do
outro mas um outro remoto outro que não
conhecemos quem é
não fazemos a mínima ideia que vai dar
lá e que tem vai dar lá e pelas coisas
que acontecem em nossa vida permanente
nos consultórios e vendo isso onde
parece que a gente está junto mas está
separado
nessas redes sociais todas com a gente
vai nas redes sociais existe um fenômeno
chamado a vácuo
não sei se vocês sabem que você começa a
falar com alguém você já está se vendo
casando com essa pessoa
o cavaco some né então não se trata mais
modernidade líquida mais modernidade
descartável
o que vamos fazer com os restos afetivos
quando a pessoa dá vácuo
não tem mais muito com tinga como fazer
não tenho que fazer com isso
ou seja desaprendemos a desejar que
desejam experiência de falta não é de
presença
eu posso desejar tudo - está aqui agora
nem chato porque eu já estou
o desejo é uma experiência de falta
não é isso passa pela falta ea gente não
sabe mais passar pela falta a gente
chama de depressão o que na verdade é
frustração
não não podemos mais suportar não ter é
isso o que a gente percebe é que essa
modernidade
o modo como a gente vai nos torna muito
reféns e uma precariedade simbólica
muito grande
a imagem vale muito mais na nossa
intimidade posta a público vai muito
mais falsa prefeito mas a apple store
não ela é colocada ali
de qualquer maneira então já fizeram
assim algumas experiências foram feitas
e surge o nome de screening noma um
pouco baseado no genoma que significa
determinados pesquisadores que ficaram
ali
analisando o que se passava nos nas
telas dos celulares de pessoas por algum
período
isso foi antes do inter 7 estou falando
num período em que se deixaram ver com
as pessoas elas lidam com a troca de
telas não é o que se viu é que ninguém
demora mais que 20 segundos em média sem
trocar de tela nem vocês imaginem a
aceleração que isso isso vai dar
não é isso ou seja uma certa fobia do
tempo lento que faz é com que é na
verdade a psicanálise nos mostra que a
gente tem um tempo a gente tem um
instante de ver um tempo para
compreender aquilo que viu em um momento
de concluir mas nesse tribunal da
internet que a gente tem que dar opinião
sobre tudo rapidamente
a gente mal viu
compartilhando não é isso sem tempo para
compreender o que estava fazendo
não é uma certa fobia como eu chamo do
tempo lento
eu acho que isso é fundamental por
exemplo quando a gente pensa que as
cidades elas perderam escala humana
atualmente né tá precisando de negócios
falou com aquela boca seca à escala
humana romana significa o que significa
que hoje em dia a rede a rua é avenida
nós precisamos então surfar nas redes
isso é incomportável a gente não vai
poder simplesmente proibir alguém de de
ter acesso ao celular e me que isso
resolve alguma coisa mas quando se perde
esse calor humano a gente tem que partir
então exatamente pra nas redes sociais
às vezes a gente comete alguns excessos
que por exemplo é susan greenfield que o
neurologista bastante conhecido na
inglaterra ela questiona o que significa
você dá para crianças de sete meses oito
meses de idade já uma tela para que ela
aprenda é as três dimensões através de
um processo bidimensional
ou seja ela já entra no mundo e deveria
ser tridimensional é virtualmente quando
talvez essa criança melhor do que isso
teria sido se ela estivesse brincando de
massinha não é lateral e uma percepção
do que é a tridimensionalidade real que
vai acontecer
vamos observar os efeitos disso nesses
meninos que já a partir de 89 anos muito
rapidamente eles sabem tudo sobre o sexo
na internet são ases da pornografia não
é isso
sabe muito mais sexo do que eu ea gente
pensa que isso vai torná-los então é uma
geração mais preparada para o sexo
ao contrário isso traz uma geração de
inibidas sexuais não é
porque eles não sabem mais o que é
brincar com massinha que o corpo do
outro é uma coisa bastante diferente não
é isso
ou seja quais são os efeitos para a
gente pensar saúde no futuro dessa
geração de inibidas se por exemplo no
japão 42% dos homens 44% das mulheres
entre 18 e 34 anos são virgens se dizer
desinteressaram completamente pelo sexo
o grande problema populacional é
exatamente em 2050 a população vai
reduzir em 20 por cento no japão se
tomarem medidas porque ninguém quer mais
trepar né
eles preferem se masturbar de ter suas
bonecas e por aí vai
ora parece que o mundo viveu não é que
estou mostrando vai bater um pouco
percebeu o seguinte é fundamental que
vocês entendam que esse grupo é chamado
de garrafa que tem a google apple
facebook amazon microsoft
eles sabem tudo sobre nós mas são vocês
mesmos que deram esses dados para eles
não foi isso ou seja entendam que não
existe almoço grátis
quando a moça é grátis vocês são
sobremesa ou seja no fundo
ao darmos isso nós simplesmente deixamos
que outros digam que a gente quer ver o
que a gente não quer isso é fundamental
porque porque no fundo esses grupos e o
facebook se você gostou disso você
também vai gostar disso
se você gostou dessa música você vai
gostar dessa música
isso é um enorme fabricação de guetos
porque por exemplo a vida amorosa ela se
passa exatamente como ela se passa pela
relatório que tem na vida
todo mundo passou por exemplo a
experiência de grupos seu lado e
recentemente de batizar que começa como
por o amor mas sabemos como isso acaba
não é isso aquilo que parecia ser uma
maravilha
sabemos que no final
o que que vai virar um processo onde nós
somos obrigados cada vez mais a colocar
imediatamente de uma maneira agressiva
que existe um componente aditivo né
deixando-a o smartphone deixou de o
dizer algo para nos conectar com outras
e do fim se a vida no smartphone passa a
ser a finalidade em si ele é um
instrumento de gozo não é só um
instrumento de comunicação não é isso
ou seja o que vamos deixar para os
nossos filhos
o que a gente percebe é que a clínica da
saúde que a gente pretende por isso o
psicanalista algo a dizer é de uma
medicina não baseada em evidências
porque nem tudo é evidente
o segredo do desejo humano não é
evidente não sabemos o como ditado
desejo mas sabemos como rastrear aquilo
que faz você gozar então o máximo que os
instrumentos todos claro são alimentados
por uma máquina capitalista é bem bem
robusta são capazes de oferecer a vocês
tudo aquilo que pode fazer vocês gozar
mas desaprendemos a desejar porque
desejar exatamente passar por essa
experiência da falta das nossas crianças
vão acabar um pouco aquela história de
que um mundo onde deixar os seus filhos
vão pensar que filhos vamos deixar nosso
mundo é a gente tem que pensar que é
preciso assim como a gente ensina é a
escrever essas crianças bombardeados
agora por telas por todos os campos
elas precisam aprender a olhar o porquê
de tanto enxergar a gente fica cego com
as coisas que a gente vê hoje em dia é
tanta a imagem que a gente não sabe mais
a gramática do olhar como é que a gente
vai colocar instaurar então essa
possibilidade de resgatar um objeto
invisível que veio para ficar
sabemos que aí ninguém vai pensar que
aqui nostalgia do tempo lampião a graça
clínica que vamos fazer a saúde que a
gente vai pensar no futuro
é exatamente para evitar que sejam um
sujeito extremamente solitários as taxas
de suicídio subiram muito vocês
perceberem o mundo tecnológico é
formidável nós vimos hoje aqui
experiência absolutamente fantásticas
a gente viu um admirável mundo novo
realmente mas como dizia minha tia velha
lá de minas tem gente que é tão pobre
que só tem dinheiro ou seja a gente vai
acumular acumulará como lá mas até que
ponto é toda essa parafernália vai nos
fazer humanos melhores
eu vou concluir como história minha eu
sou psicanalista sou psiquiatra mas eu
já fui cirurgião cardíaco uma época já
parte muitos corações e fui médico da
uti durante uma época os médicos da uti
estou falando de algo de três décadas
certa feita eu estava no plantão nos
toca trabalhava em um hospital onde toda
a equipe de plantonistas conhecia muito
bem e de repente invadir seu território
em médico amigo da casa com o filho nos
braços de seus 34 anos que tinha
encontrado no fundo da piscina
a gente pega esse menino desespero ele
era muito conhecido então começamos
imediatamente as manobras de reanimação
né cardíaca turbação choque de
adrenalina sururu massagem cardíaca ambo
para fazer respirar
fizemos isso dez minutos 20 minutos e
nada 30 minutos
teve um momento que a equipe começou a
se olhar um pro outro
mas como é que como é que disparam uma
massagem cardíaca com o pai presente
difícil então continuamos a massagear
teve moda moda eu olhei desse meu colega
ele olhou me viu e falou assim eu sei eu
sei de tudo isso mas tenta mais um
pouquinho e tentamos mais um pouquinho
no fundo tentando coração de criança ao
coração de ram é obviamente chegou uma
hora que aquele coração começou a bater
lhe cortar a conversa 25 e 30 anos
depois de 24 anos e está casado bem
super normal na vida e eu sempre tive
uma pequena vergonha um mal estar que
quando encontrava esse colega que j já
faleceu e dizia a equipe o médico que
salvou meu filho ficava com uma vergonha
pois assim foi o olhar do pai naquela
cena que salvou
aquela criança não fui eu
às vezes se eu tivesse se tivesse parado
aquela toda aquela aquela parafernalha
os equipamentos da uti
se tivesse seguido todos os protocolos
ea criança tivesse morrido
talvez não ficasse bem já não fizemos
tudo que foi possível mas tinha um olhar
do pai ali
esse olhar do pai na cena é foi tão
importante perturbador que foi o que me
motivou interrogar o resto da minha vida
o que é o olhar do pai o que é o desejo
de um pai na cena
larguei a a cirurgia me tornei
psiquiatra e psicanalista exatamente
para que possamos refletir eu pensei
sobre o papel do desejo no mundo de hoje
então o psicanalista pode fazer é
lembrar que é necessário pensarmos no
desejo e não tanto na parafernalha do
mundo que vocês estão vendo
[Aplausos]